okay
do you think there's any credibility to
Andrew Tate's theory that the elites of
the world want to take him down for
promoting that men better themselves
do you mean for this case or generally
what do you mean do you mean that they
want to take him down for this case yeah
like that like like before that he was
saying like they're going to put him in
jail like the Elites in the world are
going to put him in jail
um
yeah people always evaluate these
statements as though he's innocent but
he could be guilty right that which is
always the issue right like I might come
out and I might say well listen you know
they're going to come after me guys and
that's because the Matrix is chasing me
and I might say that because I'm just
you know like trying to get views on
YouTube or whatever but maybe I actually
did a crime I'd probably say that too
like guys they're gonna make some crazy
stuff up about me uh you know be be
ready okay and then wow I get arrested
because they found out I murdered some
kind of like see that's the Matrix well
maybe you actually did do that so do you
think they would want to take him down
though I mean I'm sure a lot of people
want to take a lot of people down
including Andrew Tate but the question
is do we see evidence of like a
concentrated effort to actually go after
him in a manner that's unfair I feel
like if we did I feel like when he got
arrested 10 months ago they would have
found a a reason to throw him
in jail or whatever and just kept them
there forever but they didn't seem to do
that so so I'll try and answer that
question so I think it's too late so in
terms of whether the elites want to take
him down I believe is not linked to this
case so basically in terms of at least
want to take him down we've seen that
he's been banned from many Medias
there's a concerted effort to basically
silence him in the UK he's not allowed
to be talked about in schools it goes to
safeguard and it goes to prevent so yeah
there is a significant fear about this
man by the impact So when you say Matrix
what you basically mean is either the
Deep State or the liberal leftist medius
immediate ideology who doesn't want to
give this guy a platform to give men
hope to give men rights in a society
where male suicide is 80 of suicide
adolescent male suicide is 80 of suicide
when when male suffering is huge in this
Society so in that aspect yes but in
terms of this case I don't think so I
believe this case is basically Romania
on its own this is my opinion I believe
it's a Romania on its own and the reason
I think that is
when you look at the way the United
States and United Kingdom do things
other than the patriarch and the
terrorism act generally speaking what
they do is they build the entire case
they make sure the case is strong enough
and then they go after the big guys in
this scenario just looking at what's
happening they're doing a very shorty
job and so when they've done such a
charity job when the evidence is so weak
when it looks like in a normal system
this wouldn't have went forward in the
United Kingdom this wouldn't have been
this would have been dropped in the
United States this would have been
dropped based on that and the terrible
job they've done I do think it's Romania
on its own
can Andrew Tate receive a fair trial in
Romania
yeah I don't see a reason why not
um so again this is just opinionated so
I believe based on what we've seen up
there now
I don't think so because I believe that
the actions that have been taken have
been very extreme in all regards and so
if this continues and is kept for the
full 180 days which I believe is
probably going to happen and then he's
put taken to trial and and and then
based on based on that I do think yeah
he will not receive a trial and be
convicted but based on the evidence I
don't think he should be convicted what
we have right now what is your ultimate
prediction for the outcome of the case
uh I think you'll be charged and
convicted at the very least with like
something related to financial crimes
but it's hard to say what the
prosecution will ultimately find
um so I think he will be convicted but I
don't think he should in terms of
financial crimes I did have the same
thoughts as Destiny previously but after
the BBC documentary
um I'm not 100 now and the reason is
because the BBC documentary tried to
relay as though they found a treasure
Trove of evidence based on money
laundering and there was Zero evidence
they flopped really badly and so based
on that if he did this massive
investigation into money laundering and
flopped they may not be evidence now I
accept that the Romanian authorities
will have a lot more powers to look and
regulate into certain look into certain
regulations and look into certain
accounts that they wouldn't so there is
a possibility but I would say based on
the evidence he should not be convicted
but based on it looks like a remaining
agenda I think it will be
has Andrew Tate been a net positive or A
negative for society
I'd stand at negative I think that most
of the advice that he gives is pretty
stock copy paste advice and I think the
entire way that he's outside of any
criminal stuff the entire way that he's
built himself up has been basically
through scamming and then partaking in
what most people would agree is like the
most immoral activity that you can do it
running casinos and running Camp
businesses I think that if you're going
to find a role model for young boys or
for young men to look up to it should be
a guy that if you want to stick with
stuck with kickboxing or done some
legitimate type of business I think it'd
be different but the fact that sex
driving aside everything they've been
done is admitted to have been scam after
scam after scam I think is is not a good
role model for people to have
um so I believe is a net positive and
the reason for it is because when you
look at the ID that he's basically
relaying I agree with Destiny they're
not like UniQue Ideas he's not someone
who's invented these ideas but what he's
able to do is these important ideas he's
been being able to penetrate mainstream
media in a significant Manner and so due
to that he's impacted the lives of many
many young males and for me males young
males are the Forgotten species issues
of society they're significantly going
through significant pain and suffering
and they don't have nothing or no way or
no one even cares about them and so for
that reason I believe he's a net
positive in terms of being a role model
look this is the issue I have also which
the Muslim Community always argue as
well they say he's not a role model look
whenever we talk about role models we
never say that somebody is a complete
role model like no one's this perfect
human being that you're gonna aspire to
be like him in a hundred percent of the
way he is what you do is you aspire to
be like that person in one aspect so
webcam business the way they became
famous exploitation of men
actually in terms of when they became
Rich they're not Role Models but in
terms of what they are random Role
Models is Aspire meant to be better
aspiring meant to work hard Inspire men
to not give up experiment and you know
basically not go into depression 80 of
men have explore are committing suicide
um you know 80 of uh rough speed rough
sleepers who are homeless are all men so
all of these things are imperative I'd
say 80 of young men are committing
suicide
yeah 80 of the people committing suicide
young men oh I'm sorry thanks for
correcting me okay a lot of people
Precision yeah yeah that would Precision
position is important and um so when you
look at that he is a massive role model
in that aspect
what percent of Andrew Tate's comments
are purely for entertainment and comedic
effect
I don't like saying anything is just for
entertainment or comedic effect the
types of jokes you tell usually
underline some sort of truth that you
believe in like if I if I'm the type of
person that tells a lot of a particular
type of joke I'm probably hinting at
something that's true if you look at any
popular like stand-up comedian generally
they joke about things but they joke
about things that hint at or reveal true
things about life so I don't believe
that there's any comedian or person that
just says things that completely and
totally betray the foundation of things
they believe I think we generally joke
about things we think are pretty true so
so so I would never ever just say like I
would say zero yeah it's not like just
jokes it's always like hinting at like
an underlying ideology yeah
um so I think there is a possibility
that you could joke and it wouldn't be
based on what you actually believe
because generally speaking you know in a
society there's gonna be certain levels
of jokes that are not allowed and so
you're not allowed to say it but that's
in terms of preventing but also you know
certain types of jokes even if you don't
believe them is going to get you
attention and attraction so that's
important but in terms of what you're
saying yeah in terms of his ideas many
of his ideas are many of his ideas when
you look at it you can when you boil it
down to the Bear Foundation you can
maybe find some strong academic argument
I believe I can find a lot of academic
Arguments for some of the many of the
points he makes
but the his delivery which is the
comedic fashion is basically there to
which which first of all made him famous
but second of all allowed him to
penetrate society and so someone like me
when I make my academic arguments maybe
people find it boring and it wouldn't it
wouldn't penetrate but someone like
Andrew does penetration so comedy is an
important factor to her basically ensure
that that happens what is one specific
what is one specific thing that Andrew
Tata said that you disagree with the
most
um this is a hard one because it goes
back and forth on this but it feels like
his women his position on women I
generally would disagree with
um the idea that like the husband owns
the wife in such a way that she's almost
like a piece of property that you
cherish your review or um Revere is
something that I disagree with but he's
he'll make other statements where he'll
say like well no there's like a mutual
respect there or if the woman agrees to
it and I mean if a woman consents to
that situation it's fine but I think in
general the way that he talks about
women as being kind of like beneath men
or something that needs to be controlled
by men and then any position that he has
on women that involves these one-sided
open relationships I think are insane
um so I've not cons I've consumed quite
a lot of tech content recently while
I've been looking into the case I'd say
basically when it comes to certain uh
well one of the ideas just an example of
when he said um you know he's talking
about knife crime in the UK which is a a
obviously a problem and then he said his
solution is to basically put them in
prison
um for like for life in Dubai and throw
away the key so if one assumes that he
wasn't saying in comedy because it
didn't seem like it was that's not like
a that's not like a logical system in
terms of like um crime punish punishment
and then the opposite on Destiny is
there something that he says that you
agree with
um I generally like messaging that like
you're the only person that can rely on
yourself I think that people need to be
a lot more internally driven I think
that right now we have a really hard
time in society with people uh facing
and overcoming any type of adversity
feels like we feel like in order to make
a good life for somebody you have to
remove every single obstacle in front of
them when we should probably be
preparing or teaching people how to deal
with obstacles and of all of Tate's
messaging I like that part the most and
the part I like the most is which I've
mentioned already is the impact he has
on young men gives men hope you know in
a society where as I said men have
forgotten men's pain is not considered
it's all about female pain and being
female suffering and you've got a
scenario where this guy actually gives
men hope gives men the opportunity and
I've had and just from my own
perspective and I'm just a small guy
within the sphere of uh social media but
the amount of people who've told me that
he's basically impacted their lives in a
positive manner taking them out of
depression giving them Focus giving them
a goal
um I think is the more single most
important aspect of what if he is
incarcerated incarcerated which society
will lose and I will I believe that is a
significant loss
if not Andrew Tate then who should young
men look up to
I've thought about this one I had
answers like 20 years ago but I'm 34 now
I don't know um in terms of Role Models
you know people have I would have said
growing up that people like Mr Rogers
even people like Bob Ross um I think
that these are like generally good
figures to look up to like people that
send messages of like hey you could be
strong but you can also be compassionate
um you know people that are good like
moral coaches or guys for life I think
are good
um but I don't know I'll get a lot of uh
I don't look at a lot of young male
inspiring figures today because that's
not kind of age out of that
um so I agree with Destiny that the
issue and the reason why it became
famous and why he's important is because
there is no other male figure you've got
if he's out there's nobody else to
replace him right now and that's the
reason why it's important some people
may argue Jordan Peterson but no I I
don't think so the guy literally is
crying on TV 24 7 he's changing his
position 24 7. he's you know his ethical
framework isn't great so there's many
issues in terms of a Jordan Peterson
that I don't think people should aspire
to be like so therefore if he wasn't
there there's a huge void I don't know
how much life advice he is but like Mr B
seems like a guy that's constantly
trying to give back to people run
Charities give money help pay for
people's medical stuff or whatever so
but what about in terms of uh um so so
of course there's good people for sure
but what I mean is what about in terms
of this aspect of that he
um he impacts on society is there
anybody else who could replace him
uh like I said I don't know if he gives
like moral lessons or coaching like
Andrew Tate does so I'm not sure if he'd
be a one-to-one replacement there
well thank you guys for coming on you
know I put a poll in the chat about who
won this debate it's like literally
right down the middle 50 50. wow
well
with all of Destiny so 51 is what needed
for the Beyond A Reasonable Doubt or
whatever
probably yes so you're a reasonable
suspicion at the moment but the the
point
yeah but I think we do I think I did
well because we got the all of Destiny's
fans probably voting for you as well so
but then you've probably got 10 fans
voting for me so oh man yeah as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible